our memories define who we are memories
are the glue that holds our mental life
together
however memories are not formed
instantaneously
instead new memories are gradually
transformed from an initially labile
state
to a more permanent states but even that
permanent state
is not necessarily permanent since i
think we've
all at some point witnessed a bit of
memory loss
but understanding the retaining
reconstructing and retrieving
of information that underpins the
process of memory formation
is of great interest and importance
because it could be used to help
understand better different
neurodegenerative diseases
and potential therapeutics it could also
be used to
maybe someday edit memories as seen in a
lot of
pop culture or to even enhance memory
formation
but to do any of this an understanding
of where memories are stored and how
memories are stored is required
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk about
memory formation and in particular
understanding
recent and remote memory formation and
then we'll look at this recent nature
publication
that shows the importance of astrocytes
in the development of
forming remote memories so recent and
remote memories
are just alternative ways of saying
short-term and long-term memory
and the really fascinating thing is that
the organization of
recent and remote memories changes as
the memory becomes more mature
a simplified overview of this process is
that recent memories depend initially on
the medial temporal lobe
that includes the hippocampus and then
remote memories
instead depends more on other brain
regions in particular the cortex
and so the really interesting question
is how new memories that form in the
hippocampus
are actually transformed into remote
memories in the cortical networks
so if we take a look at this figure from
a review article
this provides a leading hypothesis
for the fact that over time the role of
the hippocampus becomes
less important and instead the cortical
modules are more important for roommate
memory
however the temporal separation between
these events
is still unclear and it could be
different for different memories
and for you know different strengths of
those memories
and this is further supported by the
fact that the hippocampus
also seems to be important for retrieval
from what we would consider to be remote
memories
on the flip side there is also some
controversy in the literature
about the importance of the cortical
regions during the acquisition phase of
recent memory
so why is there controversy well that's
because
studying these questions is actually
really technically challenging however
there are now
lots of different hemogenetic and
optogenetic tools
that enable researchers to have
real-time reversible manipulation
of different pathways or different
receptors
in specific cells that they're trying to
study
and then these tools can be applied to
mouse models
whereby they can succumb these mice to
different
situations to test their recent and
remote memory
for example one behavioural model is
contextual fair conditioning
which is where the mice learn an
association between a distinctive place
and an affirmative offense such as a
shock
and so when that mouse is placed back
into the same context
the mice show a range of conditioned
fear responses including freezing
and this is because i guess they are
somewhat expecting that there's going to
be a shock
so it's a form of pavlovian conditioning
and so the reason i gave this particular
example
is because it's the same way that the
researchers in this recent nature paper
used to understand how astrocytes
are playing a role in the formation of
recent
and remote memories so astrocytes are
another type of cell
found in the brain along with neurons
and the function of astrocytes just
seems to keep expanding
but their main roles seem to be to sense
and modify neuronal activity
but interestingly the number of
astrocytes within the human brain
actually outnumbers the number of
neurons however
until only recently have astrocytes been
started to be investigated
in terms of its role in memory function
for example a recent study activated the
gq
signaling pathway in astrocytes within
the ca1 region
of the hippocampus when the activation
of the astrocytes
coincided with the acquisition phase of
memory formation
it was shown to enhance recent memory
emphasizing the importance of astrocytes
in memory process
so in this recent study they were
further interested in exploring the role
of astrocytes in memory formation
but this time instead of activating the
gq pathway
they activated the gi signaling pathway
so the way that they activated the gi
pathway in ca1 astrocytes was by using
the cyanoreceptor
exclusively activated by designer drugs
which only activates the pathway when
the mice are injected with clozapine and
oxide
this enables temporal control over when
this pathway is activated within the
astrocytes
so the author's time to this activation
with the delivery
of fear conditioning training when the
mice were paired
with a foot shock and a novel context
and also an auditory cue
this reversive event usually has the
result of
making the mice freeze when they're
placed back into the same context a day
later
so what happened when the gi pathway was
activated in the astrocytes
well it turned out that these mice also
froze
when they were placed in the same
context the next day
so that seemed to suggest that recent
memory was not implicated
in any way however what they found was
20 days later
when the mice were placed back into that
same context the freezing was reduced
this meant it seemed like they had
forgotten the effect of event that had
happened
which suggests that there'd been some
disruption to the formation of
remote memory for example the deficiency
was still observed
45 days after that however
whilst gi activation in the ca1
astrocytes during the acquisition of
spatial memory
selectively impacts the remote memory
but not the recent memory recall
direct neuronal inhibition of ca1
neurons
affected both the recent and remote
memory
so this seemed to suggest that the
astrocytes potentially were providing an
element of specificity
over disrupting only remote memory
formation
the question was what so as we mentioned
earlier
the formation of remote memory seems to
depend heavily
on neuronal connections between the
hippocampus and the cortex
so it was interesting to note that gi
activation of astrocytes
during the acquisition phase resulted in
the prevention of the recruitment of the
anterior
cigulate cortex during memory
acquisition
so exploring this further and
summarizing the author's
results in a very brief manner what they
found was that a population
of the ca1 neurons project to the acc
and it was these particular neurons that
seem to be modulated
by the ca1 astrocytes this seemed to
show that
the ca1 astrocytes provide
projection-specific
modulation of remote memory so these
results
really emphasize the importance of
studying non-urinal cells and memory
formation
and it also raises some interesting
questions for example how is the
specificity
achieved by which the astrocytes only
target the
ca1 neurons projecting to the acc
secondly how common is this offense is
it only seen in certain types of memory
formation
another thing i didn't mention was that
during the fair conditioning training
when a foot shock was paired with a
novel context
and an auditory cue the mice were shown
to
have a loss of remote memory in terms of
the loss of freezing when placed back
into that same context
however just by playing the same
auditory cue it didn't
see any loss of remote memory so the
auditory memory wasn't lost it was the
context the contextual memory
that was lost and so this is another
interesting thing to take from the study
and so the results suggest that there
needs to be an update to the current
models
of our understanding of recent and
remote memory
for example this figure i showed earlier
is definitely a bit
out of date since it has a neuron
centric model
and so now it seems clear that the
astrocytes are also playing a role
another thing that's interesting is i
mentioned in a previous video
that the astrocytes in the hippocampus
can become senescent
and this is something that's seen in
patients with alzheimer's disease
and so one of the questions in this was
what was the impact of having
senescent astrocytes and so by having
senescent astrocytes it now seems clear
that it can definitely
have an impact on altering memory
formation which could go hand in hand
with the symptoms seen in alzheimer's
disease patients
and so i'm just speculating here but i
think the puzzle pieces i guess are
beginning to be put together
and i think with all these new genetic
and chemo optogenetic tools available to
study
different and specific regions of the
brain i think some exciting research
should be coming out
soon so overall i thought this was a
really interesting paper
and i think i've now understand the
brain that little bit better
and hopefully you do too because as
always i hope you've learned something
and thanks for listening